[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day you know
Chris cotton our co-host he's not here
he's doing some reporting in LA but if
you were here he might tell you the back
in his day the kids used to do something
called ghost riding the whip which is
you jumped out of a car and danced
alongside it well guess what the kids
are doing it again but now with a new
song from Drake called in my feelings
they're calling it the keiki challenge
some people are calling it the do the
Shiggy that's because it was started by
comedian Shiggy but then New York Giants
wide receiver Odell Beckham jr. got
involved and that looked a little bit
something like this so as you can see it
started inside a car jumped outside the
car he's dancing this is the type of
thing that if you're a teenager and you
see this you're like alright I want to
do that these teens they've upped the
ante folks and they're doing moving cars
yeah and that looks a little bit more
like this steering wheel in the show
he's clearly not yeah that kills me
because women are already bad drivers
apparently well some people get it right
we have one more clip so in this one
look she got out of the car successful
rate okay she's moving she's good auntie
Stan nice nice she's gonna give us the
hard thing
yeah the driver was just pumping the
brakes to do that there might have been
a pedestrian crossing so bad on the ride
home my dad would just stop the car I
think we need him to come on the show
back to this yes should we stop doing
this should children stop jumping out of
cars and dancing what do we think this
is a clearly reason that we need you
know self-driving cars honestly
Tesla and Elon Musk they should totally
release something right now that does
like a Kiki challenge with self-driving
car it would be like the best yard turd
in here okay Elon Musk to you instead of
autopilot mode or insanity mode it's
like Kiki challenge a reasonable pace it
starts playing the music that's the
thing that's the problem here is that
all these cars that these girls are
falling out of are going so fast
way too fast what is happening they they
slide over neutral right which makes it
go loose okay well hitting the brakes
we're gonna make it go slower as well
yeah that first car she was going so
fast I think was like almost died
simple days are just mooning do a little
but and that's it I'm waiting for like
the country music fans to start just
jumping off of horses start dancing
alongside of horse
save a horse ride a cowboy I want this
to be part of like the next wave of
drivers chests they add it to do this or
dude to like properly and safely jump
out of a moving vehicle and then that's
just like if you can't do it then the
guys like it's like it's like sex ed
we're like well we know they're gonna be
doing it so we might as well teach them
how to do it safely did you guys pass
right away yeah you're driving good I
did I like did my test like perfectly
and then we got to a red light and I was
feeling good I was like oh there's the
there's DMV and I looked both ways at
the red light and took a left like as a
stop sign very actively like I'm gonna
make sure he knows I'm looking both ways
I drove through a stop place my driver's
ed teacher was in the back any what I do
right before like a teenager's so I
think if you're out there doing the Kiki
challenge please be safe before we move
on I want to do a quick shout out to our
youtube comment section yesterday we
were talking about a Kylie Jenner and
how whether or not she was a self-made
billionaire and we were saying you know
these days
nobody's self-made but then Karen Parker
pointed out in the comments Booker T
Washington born a slave taught himself
to read labored in exchange for a
college education became a nationally
now an african-american leader that is a
self-made person just saying yeah it's a
great point but then Kasey McBee replied
well when you think about it even he had
lawyers and other people who aided him
during his life so even Booker T might
have gotten by with a little help from
his friends so thank you for the
respectful conversation we appreciate it
and Ryan speaking of YouTube comments
what do you think people should comment
about next well tomorrow I'm gonna be
giving out relationship advice as part
of our segment where we give out
relationship advice and you can trust me
I have a girlfriend already so go ahead
and leave your comment ask me questions
I will answer them to the best of my
ability and I'm pretty sure that I'll be
uninterrupted while I do so hello and
welcome to my show-and-tell where I show
off one of the really cool projects I'm
working on and talk about it with my
coworkers today I made political
cartoons which if you don't know our
cartoons that people draw to lodge like
political complaints or nuanced
observations about society so if we
could just pull up the first one you can
see so this one sort of symbolizes
actually I want to ask you guys what
what do you think this like symbolizes
is it pixelated or did you draw it to
look like that
no no it's pixelated has been blurred
out for legal reasons yeah okay well I
guess if the pixelation were gone it
seems like it's the hair of President
Trump yes on top of the top of it yes on
top of male body parts it looks very
much like Trump if you unblurred but
yeah but you can't we can't you
mentioned nuanced yes I would say this
maybe isn't is missing some of the
nuance I don't understand what you mean
like I think you could explain sure um I
would say like kind of like how I'm
being right now which is like more
subtle is kind of what this is missing
just feels very alright I mean the head
yes thank you
high five for the drawing okay well and
so you can see it's sort of like a play
on words when I say president I read
that part
but what is it one of the what yeah
likes to play well President Trump is
the real name of him and the president
is the name you know we can just move on
to the next one
so that's America it's a dumb person and
it's had its mind removed it's lost its
looking for the it's mind and the
caption kind of explains it it says
America has totally lost its mind and
you can see he's stupid he's like
drooling and he's defecated yeah
someone's getting their period to be
honest ok well you know that could be
part of it too maybe he's getting his
period menstruating like a real idiot I
went to you went to art school yes I
guess what what was your well steal what
school for art that's there's a didn't
get into art school well I didn't apply
for art school I was trying to be a
doctor and then that was really hard
and so I changed it up and what I'm most
counted with what do you what were you
asking oh I think you answered a I will
say that this looks most similar to what
people may consider to be a political
cartoon Hey so another improvement sure
yeah a classic political cartoon Ryan
Beck no I think the quote would be
closer closer to you in inject infecting
America with truth and holding a mirror
to Lady Liberty uh Jordan Mendoza
Rhinebeck next one please
so this one it's a little it's just
words
this one's just wear it well it's a
cartoon I'd like to call a cartoon I
wonder if what you're saying is really
the opposite oh you know it's like the
cartoon is satire kind of like you know
a sin a poem peep you know that yeah
yeah it's like this is actually not a
pipe right so this is actually Jordan no
no actually because you're not saying
this is a you've written I hate Nazis
but you're not saying you hate not I get
it now yeah that makes sense I think you
got snot yeah I think Satan peep
certainty
I am a Nazi sympathizer - Jordan Mendoza
yeah I don't that's the literal
interpretation of this satirical work
well that's a little plaque on these
this is a pretty good statement or you
know art is always sometimes
misinterpreted by dumb people America so
thanks for for watching
these were my political cartoons that
you can buy on t-shirts on Jordan
Mendoza calm I should make that make
that happen right now thanks for
watching
[Music]
I've killed all my houseplants through
torture and intimidation I like to go to
baby showers because I think chocolate
is best eaten out of a diaper
I love places that give out one free
sample per customer I just wish I didn't
have to bring so many wigs and mustaches
when I'm out of salad dressing I'll use
marshmallow fluff and I make sure I'm
always out of salad dressing I tell
people I get carsick but really I just
love vomiting on dashboard
[Music]
I wish I had a car so I could try the
keiki challenge I mean I realize I would
absolutely try you should try the nuber
start dancing in traffic yeah you could
start it uber keiki challenge you could
do it
combine them you can do it inside of a
subway car right as the doors open jump
out and then a station jump out one of
the doors and then run in the next door
or perhaps out of a plane that's flying
trains planes and airmobile planes
trains and air mobiles this has been
every damn day we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you